hello there myth chasers
it's time once again to test out more of
your insane myths and questions in the
ever-changing world of fortnite battle
royale
this week it's all about those rifts
which were left behind by the space
pod but in general if you have any myths
you'd like us to waste our lives trying
please put them in the comments below
and upvote your favorites
and you could be featured next time
please think about using code adamaru in
the store
and liking this video will help me so
much anyway i will stop begging now
let's do this our first myth
comes from fishy boy who says myth can
sharks
go through rifts a nice easy one to
start with thank you very much off we
trekked to the crash site and sent that
rocket flying once again
next i grabbed a shark and attempted to
pass through the rift
i wasn't completely sure if i was timing
this correctly but as you can see in the
replay file
the shark passes through the butterfly
rift and yeah so uh sadly
a shark right now at least cannot use a
rift
hang on let me try this again using
myself as
bait wish me luck nope
mission failed we'll get them next time
sharks cannot use rifts
but let's take this to the next level
internal iconic asks what happens when
you use a rift
whilst riding a shark so essentially the
myth is the same but instead of the
shark hitting the rift the player does
instead will the fishing line hold and
let us parasail like we can at steamy
stacks
let's try this
okay so sadly this is another busted
myth
we can use the rift but the fishing line
cuts on impact and the shark simply
swims away
it looks pretty cool though but yes myth
busted
our next myth about those lovely rifts
is from oliver benham who asks myth
what happens when a boat goes through a
rift
i mean come on there's no chance a
vehicle will work on a rift is there
well oliver for you we will try it a few
of my discord members and i jumped into
a boat
which is pink for added masculinity of
course
and went straight towards the rift what
do you think happened next
it worked boats can indeed travel
through rifts
this is epic news what needs the most
attention here is the fact that
all my teammates made it through the
rift too we stayed in our positions on
the boat
everyone i attempted to maneuver the
boat in the air
using the boosters but that part of
travel seems ineffective at this height
at least
it's a shame but hey this is a great
myth which has been successfully chased
good times so let's involve this myth we
picked up a chopper
thinking this will be the same as all
vehicles won't it
well see this one for yourself this is
an epic fail
the chopper cannot access the rift bad
times bro
so when cars come out do you think
they'll be able to go into the rifts
i hope so because i want to get 10 of us
to drive straight through the same rift
and watch the carnage yeah carnage
never made a pun without even trying
anyway chop a rift
no boat rift yes let's move on okay
let's bring in those marauders and take
these rift myths to the next
level paul gamerpro asks
what happens when a marauder goes into a
rift
now this is a massive myth good shout
paolo we jumped into fork knife in a
custom game which lets us hunt down
marauders without having to fight other
teams
the real challenge with riff myths is
that the storm circle is almost
always too far away to get marauders in
the right place in time
luckily we spotted a bunch of save the
world characters
by the farm and we slowly and painfully
force them to chase the myth chasers
over to the spaceship wreck
the next issue apart from being
eliminated of course was finding a way
to get them down the mountain face
after much hassle a staircase worked a
treat
and as the storm began to approach we
managed to get them close enough to try
this
myth inch by inch kyle followed us
and then this happened
he walked into the rift and not only did
it work but he pulled his chute on the
way down
and landed safely to continue to try to
end us all
we tried this a few more times with the
same results and the thing to note is
that the rifts aren't permanently here
so even if it looks like there's a rift
there
if it's being used once it's not there
anymore
but yeah myth successfully chased for
our next test we attempted to throw a
knocked marauder into a rift and like
usual
the actual difficult part was finding
marauders and slowly leading them to the
spaceport
when we finally got them there a few
terrible throws later and
we can say for certain nope not
marauders cannot be thrown
into rifts but this idea gave me an idea
[Music]
what happens when we carry a knocked
marauder into a rift
will we drop them on the ground or could
we keep them on our shoulders and take
them for a ride
well let's try this i knocked a marauder
and b-lined for the rift
there was a few issues like the rift not
being there but eventually
i found a functioning rift and
hell yeah it worked we can knock a
marauder and carry them in the air
how cool does this look to give this
some use in game we tested this on our
own teammates
and other teams and in both
circumstances the myth remains
true we can indeed carry knocked players
or npcs through rifts
so in theory this could be a very useful
way to loot a player when on the run
pick them up and take them with you i
feel like we've learned a great deal
today
gigi all next myth please
[Music]
bearer's cousin says myth what happens
when you throw a decoy at a rift
i like it bears let's try it for this
one the steps are pretty easy but
finding decoys can take far too long
when the storm is approaching
but we did it first here's a decoy
grenade being thrown
into a rift oh okay well that was
rubbish
the grenade itself does not activate the
rift and the decoy that lands
tends to run around like a headless
chicken it's like me in a real game of
fortnite
so let's adapt this myth a little first
i built a box around the rift and threw
a decoy nearby
and finally this happened holy hut
watches batman it works decoys can
indeed use rifts
i was trying to think of a way to use
this in game and the best i can think of
is throwing a decoy into a rift to force
your enemies to shoot up into the air
and whilst they're doing that you can
line up a snipe and take out your
enemies
with no pressure at all this could be an
epic game a moment
next myth can a shark
destroy the spaceship this is too
ridiculous not to try i had to do this
and um if you follow me on twitter
you've already seen
what the heck happens here so here's the
setup i simply found
a shark took it over to the crash site
and used my body as
bait stood on top of it to see if the
shark
could destroy this invulnerable piece of
metal
check it out um well i tried this with a
single shark
i tried this with multiple sharks and i
tried it with sharks glowing different
colours too
and after being struck 20 times the
spacecraft
is indeed invulnerable but then
something
unexpected happened check this
a shark became stuck in the spaceship
and stayed there until the end of the
game
which gave me the greatest idea in the
history of fortnite
can we send a shark into outer space i
bet you weren't expecting that when you
clicked on this video
i was able to get another shark to land
in place who was kind enough to let me
begin the launch procedure
and this is what happened
got it as soon as the spaceship began to
take off the shark fell through the
vessel
and calmly went back into the blue he
wasn't even phased
by watching intergalactic space travel
that guy's super chill
but to confirm no we can't send a shark
to space in fortnite maybe i should make
this the thumbnail for the video
it would confuse everyone totally worth
it
oh random myth alert we were trying to
find a way to die to a shark
and i wondered what happened when a
shark hits a crash mat
well here it is he has the time of his
life
and we all know if you make the shark
happy it won't attack you
it will it will it will attack you it's
a shark
don't trust sharks
so there we have it a bunch of myths
about rifts fortnite is at its best when
new content drops like this
and we can try and find ways to break it
and use it in games
imagine the shenanigans we can have with
functioning cars it's gonna be epic
just as an fyi when using the replay
files you may have noticed
some uh weird things happening like
floating astronauts or the rifts being
available even when the ship is there
too
this is simply an issue with scrubbing
around in replays
giving us the most memorable memeable
images
in fortnite history on screen now are
the legends who use code adamaru thank
you so much for supporting me this
season
i am truly blessed by hot watch and
graham i'm
adam from playstation grenade it's been
an absolute pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time
hmm